spoilers for Attack on Titan episode 88
the final chapters special one you've
been warned
the hour-long special of Attack on Titan
season 4 part 3 the Final Chapter
special one has brought us one step
closer to the end of the series and
invites us one step further into the
broken mind of Aaron Yeager
enter it at your own peril
thank you
the beginning of episode 88 gives us 11
and a half minutes of Master Class
Attack on Titan we witness a beautifully
scored and directed depiction of the
horrors of the rumbling and the
rightfully menacing and villainous
justification that Aaron has for it we
essentially watch as Aaron comes to turn
with what he must do accepting that this
is the only outcome and dissociating to
the point of considering the genocide of
the entire world to be his absolute
freedom
let's try to understand this step by
step because Aaron's mind is anything
but simple
[Music]
his dialogue first starts with notes of
ambiguity and questioning his first line
is that later though I'm not exactly
sure how far in the future I Massacre
these people
he says that it is already determined
that he will and must do this
in this moment at the beginning of the
episode we do sympathize with Aaron he
gives the impression that he doesn't
necessarily want to do this but that he
simply must he is willed forward by his
knowledge of the future blindly pursuing
what he sees as the only option
he mentions that he imagines they
couldn't find a way to save Paradise in
the future and had to resort to killing
everyone he even asks what his mother
would think of what he's doing
this internal monologue he has creates
this stark contrast to the Aaron we left
off with last season the manipulative
all-powerful Mastermind and bearer of
the founding Titan and the one with the
humanity we remember
[Music]
it is the classic struggle of Fate
versus Free Will as Aaron watches a
young child get assaulted in an Alleyway
he begins to walk away acknowledging
that in the future he will kill this
child in the rumbling
what good would helping him do now who
is he to act good now and protect him
knowing that he will kill all of them
someday like some cruel act of kindness
just prolonging their suffering
yes he has the free will to help him in
this moment but if he knows he is
destined to kill him why bother
we as the Watchers are placed in this
back and forth between the past and the
present the present and the future
however you want to call it we are put
in Aaron's shoes
as Aaron cries apologizing unrelentingly
to the young kid he could not help but
save that the future foretold he would
do we simultaneously witness as Aaron
brings about the child's death
we are left with this beautifully tragic
yet horrifying reality
and Aaron fears who he will become but
cannot help but do it
at this moment it is difficult not to
sympathize with Aaron
but then we are quickly reminded of what
Aaron truly believes
when he is not justifying his actions as
just being a pawn to the Future a
harbinger of the end his own
justification
the reality of the world outside of the
walls was different from the world I
dreamed of
I was disappointed I wanted this
I wanted to wipe everything away
[Music]
in a single moment we remember that this
is still the path Aaron chose
he crushes those children with
conviction he is sorry but that will not
stop what he knows he must do
the destruction
the massacre
the genocide
[Music]
Aaron has convinced himself that this
scene this view from the sky above the
walls seeing the world that he and Armin
once dreamed of is freedom
he has reached the Pinnacle and finally
done it
regardless of the means he has reached
that end and convinced himself that this
genocide is in fact absolute freedom
his mind is broken
as I'm sure all of ours would be too
were we just a child given all the power
to destroy the world and the foreboding
someday you would do it
who are you to argue otherwise
if you are destined to do this and a
part of you might believe that this is
right
why bother trying to do anything else
what began as a sympathetic
demonstration of Aaron's feelings of
being trapped on this path that the
Future Has inevitably laid out for him
some form of Twisted justification
it devolves into the reality of it all
Aaron wanted all of this
he will become Reiner he will become
worse than him he will take away the
lives of Marlins and the rest of the
world if it means that paradise can keep
theirs in the pursuit of absolute
freedom from the Terrors of humanity
outside of the walls
forever
the most interesting line I think from
this episode comes from Aaron's dialogue
with the remnants of the survey corps
where he tells them that they are free
to protect the world's freedom and he is
free to keep moving forward
this goes a long way in justifying
Aaron's actions as well or at least how
he sees it in his mind and that freedom
is subjective
Aaron acknowledges that his freedom is
derived from taking the rest of the
worlds from them
and forcing them down into absolute
subjugation and Massacre as His Kind
were for thousands of years
Marley and freedom on the other hand
means using eldians as tools and
scapegoats to take the blame of
History's massacres
the current survey corps freedom is
given to them by Aaron it is the freedom
to choose how to act with their Titans
and to try and protect the rest of the
world's Freedom if they desire it Aaron
wants to protect them he won't take away
their freedom and thus it is their
freedom to decide what they want to do
with it
it brings up one of the most interesting
themes in Attack on Titan and one of the
most confusing as well
The Clash of views amidst an eternal
cycle and back and forth of who is the
enemy and who is the victim
and the justification behind Aaron's
actions knowing that there will only be
one true Freedom among those different
groups of people when the rest are
eliminated
after what he's been through what he's
seen in the past present and future all
the different ideas and clashes of
morals everything this is all Aaron can
do to finally end it
aside from that I think this episode was
beautifully made from the pacing to the
soundtrack to the attention it gives to
each character in this finale all of it
kept me intrigued and excited for the
finale to come
let me know your thoughts and as always
this has been the anime culture corner I
hope you enjoyed the video don't forget
to like And subscribe for future
in-depth show manga and character
analyzes